For centuries, Muslims have been
claiming that according to the Quran,
the Torah and the Gospel have been
corrupted.
More recently, Christians have been
responding to this charge by quoting the
Quran and showing that it never once
criticizes the text of the Jewish and
Christian scriptures. On the contrary,
the Quran affirms the inspiration,
preservation, and authority of the Torah
and the Gospel.
But our Muslim friends just don't see
it. They call us liars. They say we're
distorting what the Quran says.
So what's going on here?
How are Christians and Muslims looking
at the exact same Quran, a Quran that
repeatedly claims to be perfectly clear
and coming to completely different
conclusions about what it says?
And even more importantly, how can we
decide who's right?
Well, fortunately for us, we've got some
tools derived from Bayes' theorem that
can help us get to the bottom of this.
But not in the zoot sense.
Welcome to the Bayesian Islamic dilemma.
In this video, we'll go through some
basic principles of Bayesian reasoning.
If this is new to you, don't worry, it's
not very complicated.
Then we'll apply these principles to
what Muslims and Christians are claiming
about the Quran. And finally, we'll see
why we're looking at the same evidence
but coming to radically different
conclusions.
Let's get started.
Guess what?
You use Bayesian reasoning all the time.
You just don't realize it.
Bayes' theorem is a formula for updating
your thinking as new evidence comes in.
Again, you do this all the time.
Suppose it's 10:00 p.m.
and I want to tell my wife something,
but I don't want to wake her up if she's
already asleep.
She normally goes to bed between 9:30
and 10:30. So if it's 10:00,
let's say there's a 50/50 chance that
she's already asleep.
The probability that she's asleep is 50%
or 0.5. And the probability that she's
awake is 50% or 0.5.
But then I stumble upon some evidence.
I walk by our bedroom door and I can
tell from the light escaping from the
bottom of the door
that the lights are still on in our
room.
Now, it's possible that she fell asleep
with the lights on, but she generally
turns off the lights when she goes to
bed.
So,
the evidence, namely that the lights are
on, makes way more sense if she's awake
than if she's asleep.
I conclude, therefore, that she's
probably still awake.
Notice what just happened.
There were two hypotheses. Hypothesis
one, my wife is still awake. Hypothesis
two, my wife is asleep.
These two hypotheses initially seemed
equally probable. So I would have
assigned each hypothesis a probability
of 50% or 0.5.
But some new evidence came in, the
lights being on,
and this evidence massively favored one
hypothesis over the other. So much so
that I became something like 99% sure
she was still awake.
How did I update my confidence in the
hypothesis that my wife was still awake?
I applied Bayes' theorem. More
specifically, I applied what's called
the odds form of Bayes' theorem, which,
here again, you do all the time.
We normally think of odds in gambling.
This team is a two-to-one favorite. That
horse is a ten-to-one underdog.
You can update gambling odds based on
new evidence the same way you update the
probability of a hypothesis being true.
If a horse named Bayes' theorem is a
ten-to-one underdog, but you suddenly
find out that the fastest horse in the
race is sick, that will change the odds
of Bayes' theorem winning.
The odds form of Bayes' theorem is
especially helpful when we're trying to
figure out how some piece of evidence
favors one hypothesis over another.
Here's a simple version of the odds form
of Bayes' theorem.
This just says that we get the new odds
by multiplying the prior odds by the
likelihood ratio. That sounds fancy, it
isn't. We already did it with no trouble
at all.
If hypothesis one is my wife is still
awake and hypothesis two is my wife is
asleep and E is the evidence that the
bedroom lights are on, we see that the
prior odds, the odds before we factored
in the evidence, were one-to-one.
They were even.
The likelihood is how likely the
evidence is or how much the evidence
would be expected if the hypothesis is
true.
So, we read this as the probability of
the evidence given hypothesis one or the
probability of the evidence assuming
hypothesis one is true.
Using our example, this would be the
probability that the lights are on
assuming my wife is still awake.
And this would be the probability that
the lights are on assuming my wife is
asleep.
Since the likelihood on top is much
higher than the likelihood on bottom,
the evidence is going to strongly favor
hypothesis one over hypothesis two even
though we started with the odds being
even.
So, the impact of the evidence is that
the odds are now heavily in favor of
hypothesis one.
The odds were one-to-one, but the
evidence makes far more sense given the
truth of hypothesis one.
We don't even need actual numbers to say
that based on the evidence, hypothesis
one is probably true and hypothesis two
is probably false.
Good so far?
Awesome.
Now, we can simplify this even more
because all we're comparing are, on the
one hand, the prior probabilities, the
probabilities before we factor in the
evidence, and on the other hand, how
likely the evidence is on each
hypothesis.
So,
we can rewrite the argument for my wife
being awake like this. Hypothesis one,
my wife is still awake. Hypothesis two,
my wife is asleep. Evidence E, the
bedroom lights are on.
Premise one, the prior probability of
hypothesis two is not much greater than
the prior probability of hypothesis one.
Premise two, the probability of the
evidence is much greater on hypothesis
one than it is on hypothesis two.
This is just another way of saying that
the evidence strongly favors hypothesis
one over hypothesis two.
Conclusion, my wife is very probably
awake. We say very probably because it's
something like 99% probable.
Now, for premise one, why did I write
this as the prior probability of
hypothesis two is not much greater than
the prior probability of hypothesis one?
We said that before we factored in the
evidence, the odds were pretty much
even, 50/50.
So why write it like this?
Well, because it's all we need.
The evidence strongly favors hypothesis
one over hypothesis two.
But if the prior probability of
hypothesis two were much, greater than
the prior probability of hypothesis one,
the evidence might not do much.
To go back to our example,
suppose the prior probability of
hypothesis one were much, much lower.
Suppose I already knew that my wife took
a bunch of Ambien at 9:00 p.m. and that
this would almost certainly make her
fall asleep by 10:00 p.m.
The prior probability of the hypothesis
that she was asleep at 10:00 p.m. would
be much higher than the prior
probability that she was awake at 10:00
p.m.
Then, when I bring in new evidence, the
lights are on, I might still think it's
more probable that she's asleep.
On Ambien, she could have fallen asleep
even with the lights on.
So, if we're going to say that some
piece of evidence shows that a
hypothesis is probably true, it helps to
know that the prior probability of an
alternative hypothesis wasn't already
much greater.
And now we have all the tools we need
for a simple Bayesian version of the
Islamic dilemma.
Consider two hypotheses. First
hypothesis, the Quran confirms the
inspiration, preservation, and authority
of the Torah and the Gospel in the
possession of Jews and Christians. We'll
call this the confirmation hypothesis.
Second hypothesis, the Quran claims that
the Torah and the Gospel in the
possession of Jews and Christians have
been corrupted. We'll call this the Dawa
hypothesis.
To avoid any potential bias, let's
pretend that we have no clue what the
Quran says about the previous
scriptures. Our minds are completely
open. Maybe Muhammad said the previous
scriptures were corrupted, maybe he
didn't. We don't know yet.
And for the sake of argument, to keep
things simple, let's assume that these
are the only two hypotheses. There are
other possibilities. For instance, the
Quran could say nothing about the
previous scriptures. The Quran could say
that there were no inspired scriptures
before Muhammad, and so on.
But to keep this simple, we'll assume
that the Dawa hypothesis and the
confirmation hypothesis are the only
options.
Before we open the Quran to see what it
says, the Dawa hypothesis and the
confirmation hypothesis are both
entirely plausible. A man who comes
along in the 7th century and claims to
be a prophet could say that the previous
scriptures were corrupted, or he could
say that the previous scriptures weren't
corrupted.
Prior to looking at what the Quran says,
I don't see any reason to favor one
hypothesis over the other.
So, we can say that the prior
probabilities are pretty even, but we'll
go with the even more modest premise.
The prior probability of the Dawa
hypothesis isn't much greater than the
prior probability of the confirmation
hypothesis.
Now, what's our evidence going to be?
Ideally, we would include everything the
Quran says about the previous
scriptures, but this video would end up
being several hours long. So, let's
focus on seven verses.
Sura 7, verse 157.
Those who follow the messenger, the
unlettered prophet, whom they find
inscribed in the Torah and the Gospel
that are with them, it is they who shall
prosper.
This verse is about Jews and Christians
who find Muhammad inscribed in the Torah
and the Gospel that are with them.
In Sura 2, verse 85, Allah is
criticizing the Jews for following parts
of the Torah and not following other
parts of the Torah.
Allah condemns them for this, and he
says, "Do you then believe in part of
the book and disbelieve in part?
And what is the recompense of those who
do so but disgrace in the life of this
world? And on the day of resurrection,
they shall be consigned to the most
severe punishment."
In Sura 4, verse 47, Allah says to the
people of the book, "O you unto whom the
book has been given, believe in what we
have sent down, the Quran, confirming
that which is with you, before we blot
out faces and turn them backwards, or
curse them as we cursed those who broke
the Sabbath. And the command of God
shall be fulfilled."
The Quran confirms the book that is
still with the people of the book, Jews
and Christians.
In Sura 5, verse 43, some Jews come to
Muhammad to settle a dispute. Allah
responds, "Why do they come to you for
judgment, O Muhammad, when they have the
Torah before them, wherein is the
judgment of Allah?
Yet they turn back after that, and these
are not the believers."
According to the Quran, Jews don't need
the Quran because they have the Torah.
In Sura 5, verse 47, Allah commands
Christians, "Let the people of the
Gospel judge by what Allah hath revealed
therein.
If any do fail to judge by the light of
what Allah hath revealed, they are no
better than those who rebel."
According to the Quran, Christians are
supposed to judge by the Gospel, not by
the Quran.
If the Torah and the Gospel have been
corrupted, Jews and Christians have
nowhere else to turn, because in Sura 5,
verse 68, Allah tells Muhammad to say,
"O people of the book, you have no
ground to stand upon unless you stand
fast by the Torah, the Gospel, and all
the revelation that has come to you from
your Lord."
Interestingly, the Torah and the Gospel
were authoritative even for Muhammad. In
Sura 10, verse 94, Allah says,
"But if you, Muhammad, are in doubt as
to what we have revealed to you, ask
those who read the book before you.
Certainly, the truth has come to you
from your Lord, therefore you should not
be of the disputers."
So, if Muhammad has doubts about his
revelations, he can simply go to the
people of the book to make sure his
revelations line up with our
revelations.
Putting just these seven verses
together, the Quran claims that it's
affirming scriptures that are with Jews
and Christians. It claims that these
scriptures are written down. It says we
have to believe in all of our book, not
just parts. It claims that Jews and
Christians must judge by these
scriptures. It claims that Jews and
Christians have no other ground to stand
upon apart from these scriptures.
And it claims that these scriptures are
authoritative even for Muhammad.
Back to our two hypotheses.
According to the confirmation
hypothesis, the Quran confirms the
inspiration, preservation, and authority
of the Torah and the Gospel in the
possession of Jews and Christians.
According to the Dawa hypothesis, the
Quran claims that the Torah and the
Gospel in the possession of Jews and
Christians have been corrupted.
Clearly, the seven Quran verses we read
fit the confirmation hypothesis
perfectly.
These verses say exactly what we would
expect the Quran to say if the
confirmation hypothesis is true.
But they make no sense whatsoever if the
Dawa hypothesis is true.
If the Dawa hypothesis is true, it makes
absolutely no sense for the Quran to say
it's affirming the scriptures that are
with Jews and Christians and written
down with Jews and Christians.
It makes no sense for Allah to say we
have to believe in all of our book and
not just in parts of our book. It makes
no sense for the Quran to order Jews and
Christians to judge by corrupt
scriptures. It makes no sense for the
Quran to say that Jews and Christians
have no other ground to stand upon apart
from these scriptures. And it makes no
sense for the Quran to say that Muhammad
can only confirm his revelations by
going to people who are reading corrupt
scriptures.
What does this mean? It means that the
evidence massively favors the
confirmation hypothesis over the Dawa
hypothesis.
We write this as the probability of the
evidence given the confirmation
hypothesis is much greater than the
probability of the evidence given the
Dawa hypothesis. That's another way of
saying that the evidence strongly favors
the confirmation hypothesis over the
Dawa hypothesis.
The conclusion we would draw is other
evidence held equal, the confirmation
hypothesis is much more probable than
the Dawa hypothesis.
Notice I included the phrase other
evidence held equal because we're
granting the possibility that our Muslim
friends could conceivably offer some
powerful evidence that we've overlooked,
powerful evidence that would change our
minds and convince us that the Dawa
hypothesis is probably the correct
position.
But we keep listening to their
responses, and we're not seeing anything
that even remotely supports the Dawa
hypothesis.
All the other evidence that we haven't
included in this video simply offers
more support for the confirmation
hypothesis.
So, my version of the Bayesian Islamic
dilemma runs as follows.
We have two hypotheses. One, the
confirmation hypothesis, the Quran
confirms the inspiration, preservation,
and authority of the Torah and the
Gospel in the possession of Jews and
Christians. And two, the Dawa
hypothesis, the Quran claims that the
Torah and the Gospel in the possession
of Jews and Christians have been
corrupted.
Our evidence is seven Quran verses.
Premise one, the prior probability of
the Dawa hypothesis isn't much greater
than the prior probability of the
confirmation hypothesis. Premise two,
the evidence strongly favors the
confirmation hypothesis over the Dawa
hypothesis. Conclusion, other evidence
held equal, the confirmation hypothesis
is much more probable than the Dawa
hypothesis.
If our Muslim friends don't come up with
some overriding evidence, we'll simply
conclude that the confirmation
hypothesis is very probably true.
And to make this a proper Islamic
dilemma, we can add,
"The Quran contradicts the Torah and the
Gospel on fundamental doctrines,
therefore, Islam is very probably
false."
I should go ahead and point out here
that this isn't some new argument. Just
as you use Bayesian reasoning all the
time without realizing it, if you've
been using the Islamic dilemma, you've
been using Bayesian reasoning without
realizing it.
We have our hypothesis, Muslims have
their hypothesis. We look at what the
Quran says, and it massively favors our
hypothesis over their hypothesis.
We give our Muslim friends every
opportunity to present evidence that
outweighs our evidence, and they never
come close.
So, we have every reason to conclude
that our hypothesis is the correct one.
This raises an obvious question that I
brought up at the beginning of this
video.
If Christians and Muslims are looking at
the same verses in the same book,
why are we coming to completely
different conclusions?
Well, that takes us back to Bayes.
Remember, as one of our premises, I said
that the prior probability of the Dawa
hypothesis isn't much greater than the
prior probability of the confirmation
hypothesis.
In other words, before we actually
examine the evidence, we don't have a
reason to strongly favor one hypothesis
over the other.
So, we turn to the evidence with open
minds and realize wow, this evidence
massively supports the hypothesis that
the Quran confirms the inspiration,
preservation, and authority of the Torah
and the Gospel.
We don't see any evidence that suggests
otherwise. Therefore, we conclude that
the Quran very probably confirms the
inspiration, preservation, and authority
of the Torah and the Gospel. Since the
Torah and the Gospel contradict the
Quran on fundamental doctrines, the
Quran is very probably wrong.
But, our Muslim friends don't approach
the evidence this way.
They reject the first premise.
Why?
Because they've been told all their
lives that the Quran says the Torah and
the Gospel have been corrupted.
And they've been trained all their lives
not to question what they hear from
their sheikhs and imams and da'ees.
So, they've already decided that the
probability of the Dawa hypothesis is
one. It's 100% true.
And since they've already decided that
the Dawa hypothesis is 100% true and
that they can't question this
hypothesis, no amount of evidence can
convince them otherwise.
So, when we point out that Allah says
he's confirming the scriptures we have
and that we have to judge by our
scriptures,
our Muslim friends are already convinced
that Allah can't possibly mean what he
says.
He must mean something completely
different from what he says in the
Quran.
This means that for our Muslim friends,
at least for most of them,
the evidence is completely irrelevant.
We're going where the evidence points.
They're going with what they've been
told,
even though it completely contradicts
the evidence.
Now, I presented my Bayesian Islamic
dilemma without bringing in any
sophisticated math. If you'd like to see
a Bayesian Islamic dilemma with some
number crunching,
be sure to watch Fes argument over at
Inspiring Philosophy. The link is in the
description box.
[Music]